The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Let's get started.
We want to wrap up today
our discussion of atoms
without external
field, and then discuss
what happens when we put atoms
into external magnetic fields.
Last class, we talked
about isotope shifts,
and there was a question, how
big are those isotopes for some
of your favorite atoms?
I just looked up
some information
on lithium, which
is a light atom,
and this paper here
shows calculations
compared with experiments.
The isotope shift between
lithium six and lithium seven
due to the mass, lithium
six to lithium seven,
is about 10 gigahertz.
The volume effect is only two
megahertz, 1,000 times smaller.
However, the precision
of experiments
is such that if you
find an isotope shift,
the mass effect can
be exactly calculated
from the atomic masses, you
can still get information
about the size of the
atomic nucleus out of it.
So this is the example of a
light atom, 10 gigahertz mass
effect, two megahertz
volume effect.
And here is a rubidium atom.
The isotope shift of the
D1 line between 85 and 87
is 77 megahertz only.
The mass shift is 56
megahertz, and the remainder
is mainly the volume effect.
There's a specific mass effect
due to electronic correlations
if you calculate electrons,
which I think is small here
but I don't want to discuss it.
We can now compare
the mass effect
in rubidium versus lithium.
First of all, the shift
compared to infinite mass.
the reduced mass effect,
is much bigger in lithium.
It's 20 times bigger in
lithium than in rubidium.
However, when you go from
lithium six to lithium seven,
the mass changes by 15%,
so the delta m over m
is also much larger for
lithium than rubidium.
And if you add
those two factors,
you find that the mass
effect is 200 times larger
in lithium, 10 gigahertz
versus 50 megahertz.
The nuclear volume
effect is two megahertz
for lithium, 20
megahertz for rubidium,
so that sets the scale.
Any questions about that?
Let me come back to one
other question which
we discussed last
class, and this
was the question
about if you have
a deformation of a
nucleus, or if you have
any kind of isotropic
shape of an object,
what is the minimum
angular momentum in order
to observe it?
I know a lot of you
got confused about it,
so I want to discuss
the same thing again,
but now focusing on two
different frames, the lab frame
and the body-fixed frame.
I hope you find this
discussion insightful.
So let's assume we have an
object, it can be a molecule.
Actually, you have a
homework assignment
whether you can observe
a permanent dipole
moment of a molecule,
and this will lead you
into a discussion of lab
frame versus body-fixed frame.
But let's assume
we have an object,
assume it's a nucleus, which
has a really odd shape.
However, if it has
angular momentum of zero,
all you have is one level.
If you have an angular momentum
of 1/2, you have two levels,
and you can now define
in the laboratory
that the energy difference
is due to the magnetic dipole
moment, for instance, or
the electric dipole moment
if you put in electric field.
If you have I equals
1, you can have
three levels, E1, E0, E minus 1.
Let's say you have put the
atoms into an electric field
gradient.
You can then ask if E0 is in
the middle between up and down,
plus 1 or minus 1, or whether
it's displaced or not.
And depending whether this is
larger or smaller than zero,
you would say there is a
quadrupole moment which
is larger or smaller than zero.
In other words, what I'm telling
you is if you have only one
level, I equals 0,
you can't say anything
about the shape of the object.
If you have two levels, you
can determine a dipole moment.
If you have three
levels, by the deviation
from the equidistance, you can
find a higher order moment.
But now comes the point.
You can now take two positions.
You can say that for low I,
the deformation of a magnetic
moment for I equals
0 cannot be measured.
Therefore, it is zero.
Or you can say deformation
exists, but only not in the lab
frame but in the
body-fixed frame.
So in other words, you would
say that the deformation exists
always.
It's just a measurement problem.
At low angular momentum,
I cannot measure.
Or the other statement would be,
well, if you can't measure it,
[INAUDIBLE], it means
it doesn't exist.
So which statement or which
conclusion is correct?
This is the body-fixed
frame argument,
and this is more based
on the lab frame.
Well, I would say the lab frame
argument is always correct
because you can't
measure it, you
can't determine it in the
lab, but let me go from there.
Let's assume we have
an object, and we
think it has a deformation but
it has a low angular momentum
phase.
Can we still say that
in its body-fixed frame,
we have an object which
has a deformation or not?
Now, my personal opinion
is the following.
It really depends.
If you have a system
where you can have
angular momentum
without changing
the internal structure.
For instance, I have this stick,
and I can just spin it up,
and if I can spin it up, I can
get an angular momentum wave
packet, I can orient it and
measure its deformation.
Then I think I would say, even
if this state has zero angular
momentum, it has a
deformation, and the way
I know it because if I
add angular momentum,
I can measure the deformation.
I cannot measure it at
low angular momentum.
So then you would say in
the body-fixed system,
there is a deformation, but
it only manifests itself
in the lab frame if I
add angular momentum.
However, you may have an
object, let's say a molecule,
which is so weakly bound
that one quantum of angular
momentum due to centrifugal
forces rips it apart.
That exists.
Extremely bound state which
cannot provide enough binding
force to withstand even one
unit of angular momentum.
So that's an object
which you cannot rotate,
you cannot transfer any angular
momentum without destroying it,
without ripping it apart.
And now to say that this
molecule has a dipole moment
or has some anisotropy, you're
making a statement which cannot
be tested at all.
So at that point, you
should rather say,
what matters is what I
can measure in the lab,
and I will never
be able to measure
any deformation in the lab.
So the first example
with the stick
will apply to a very
stable molecule which
may have a dipole
moment, and you
assume it has the same
dipole moment whether it's
rotating or not.
And then you would say
at zero angular momentum,
I cannot measure the dipole
moment but I know it exists
in the body-fixed frame.
If you have a
nucleus, and you have
sort of a wave function of
the protons and neutrons,
and it's I equals 0, you
will not find any moment.
At least for the
ground state of nuclei,
when you add angular
momentum, you really
change the internal structure.
You have to promote
nucleons to higher orbits,
so you cannot add angular
momentum and still have
the same object.
So therefore, you have
to say the ground state
with I equals 0 has no
deformation, because there
is no way to ever find
[INAUDIBLE] deformation,
so it doesn't exist.
But there are excited
states of nuclei
which have a deformation,
and these deformed nuclei
can be put into a multiplex
of angular momentum states.
So then you would see, I have
the same kind of nucleus,
but at different
angular momentum states.
At higher angular
momentum states,
you can define [INAUDIBLE]
determine quadrupole moments
and things like this.
And then you may say the
same internal state has now
a non-rotating state, and
you would still be tempted,
and you are correct with that,
to associate a deformation even
in the non-rotating state.
I hope those remarks help
you reconcile the two aspects
whether you have an object which
is stable enough to be spun up,
and then I think
you can always talk
about the body-fixed frame.
But if you have an object
where you change the internal
structure when you add
angular momentum, I think,
for fundamental reasons,
you cannot associate any
deformation with it.
Any questions about that?
Let me just write
down the summary.
The definition of a deformation
in a body-fixed frame
makes sense only if you can
add or change angular momentum
without significantly changing
the internal structure.
Questions?
I think the computer is set up.
I cannot go backward
in Presentation mode.
What I want to discuss
next is give you
a little bit of an historic
summary how spectroscopy
of hydrogen is developed,
in particular also focusing
on one important discovery,
the discovery of QED
through the Lamb shift.
Of course, you all love hydrogen
because it's the simplest atom
but it has so much
interesting physics in it.
I've summarized for you here
some papers on hydrogen,
and I used them to
illustrate several points.
I will show you that actually,
the discovery of the Lamb shift
had precursors.
10 years before the Lamb
shift was discovered,
people had even some
idea that something
may be wrong with
the understanding
of the structure of hydrogen.
So you can say they came
so close, people 10 years
before, in realizing
the Lamb shift,
there were people who
maybe missed the Nobel
prize by just a tiny little bit.
They had all the
insight that there
may be QED correction
in hydrogen.
They just didn't
have the technology
to measure it accurately enough.
The second example
I want to show
is that we always talk about
fundamental limitations,
but fundamental limitations
can disappear in time
because they may not be as
fundamental as they appear.
So for instance,
there were limitations
with the limitations
of the Lamb shift
because you had a short
lifetime of p states,
but with the event of
two photon transition,
you can go from s to
s and s to d states,
and therefore map
out Lamb shifts
with much, much higher
precision not limited
by the finite
lifetime of p states.
Finally, you would say Lamb
shifts are small splittings,
and for many, many
years, Lamb shifts
were measured by
making radio frequency
transitions between
two s and two p states.
Well, today, the most accurate
measurement of the Lamb shift
is with an optical
transition where
you need a much, much
higher relative precision
to see the tiny Lamb shift.
But optical metrology with
direct frequency measurements
and frequency combs has so
much improved in precision
that now, an optical
measurement, even if it comes
to a tiny difference, is
more accurate than a direct
[INAUDIBLE].
So I think the
history of hydrogen
shows you that
technology can completely
change the paradigm how
measurements are made.
Fundamental limits
disappear because new tools
or new insight is available.
And also, I find it interesting
that discoveries often
have precursors, and people
have a hunch, know about it,
and then finally,
it is discovered.
Let me just take you through
some historic papers.
This paper is 1933, 15
years before the Lamb shift,
and it says that one
possible explanation
for some discrepancy of the
structure of the Balmer lines
is that the effect
of the interaction
between the radiation field and
the atom has been neglected.
That's QED.
You cannot just calculate the
structure of the hydrogen atom
from the Coulomb field.
You have to allow the
radiation field, all the modes
of the vacuum to be included.
So this insight
is not due to Lamb
It was there already, 1933.
Same year, look at the
title, "On the Breakdown
of the Coulomb Law for
the Hydrogen Atom."
People speculated or discussed
that the Coulomb law will not
be valid at very
small distances.
This is ultimately what QED,
raided correction, the Lamb
shift, vacuum
polarization all is about.
Finally, people had an
understanding of the hydrogen
atom, and they
measure-- I want you
to keep that in mind--
they did optical.
They measured the Balmer lines
of hydrogen and deuterium,
and they couldn't
fully resolve it
because of the finite
lifetime of the peak state,
but there was some
hunch when you
try to get the envelope from
the underlying structure
that there was a discrepancy.
It was just not significant
enough to say for sure,
there is an
additional line shift
which is not accounted
for by theory.
There was a
discussion that there
is a deviation of the Coulomb
law, but here is the insight.
As was indicated by
previous authors,
the interaction required
to change the Coulomb law
at small distances
is much too large
to be accounted for
by the assumption
of a finite size of
electron and proton.
So the Coulomb field
has to be modified
at short distances in a
much stronger way than just
the finite size of the proton.
We'll talk about the finite
size of the proton in a minute.
And then, of course,
1947, UIF oscillators
have been developed in
the pursuit of radar,
experimental tools are there
now-- high power IF sources,
cumulative sources,
and such, and then
Lamb and Retherford
in his landmark paper
look at the fine structure
of the hydrogen atom,
and this is the famous result.
They measured transitions as
a function of magnetic field,
and you see the solid
line, which I think
was the theory without
the Lamb shift.
The dashed line is the hyper
fine structure of hydrogen,
and the lines converge,
and the difference
is 1,000 megacycles, the first
determination of the Lamb
shift.
So this was 1947.
It's interesting
that it's just one
or two weeks later, there is
a theoretical paper by Hans
Bethe providing an explanation
for the Lamb shift,
so already coming up
with the first model
how to account for QED.
I didn't look it
up in detail, but I
thought the spirit was similar
to what I presented you
in class, that the
electromagnetic zero point
energy is shaping the electron
and leading to corrections.
But it's amazing that
within weeks, theorists
figured nearly out, yes,
this is the explanation.
This is how we have
to explain the theory.
For a number of years,
people pursued measurements
of the Lamb shifts with
higher and higher accuracy.
I just like the
last sentence here.
This is now the next paper by
Willis Lamb and Retherford,
and they are sort of saying that
they wanted to measure the Lamb
shift with higher
precision, but then they
said, "the program was
large and encountered
unexpected difficulties
which required much more time
to surmount.
As a result, the paper promised
two years ago was delayed."
I think this applies to many,
many papers to be written,
but here, the authors
even say that upfront,
it took us two years
longer to do the research
than we initially anticipated.
You see now the
growing accuracy.
We have the Lamb shift, which
is on the order of 1,000
megacycles, one gigahertz,
and the precision
is now in the 100
kilohertz range.
This was the technology
of the original discovery.
Then there was a next
generation of experiments
on the Lamb shift using
separated [? oscilloatomic ?]
fields, [INAUDIBLE] techniques.
We'll talk about that
later in the course.
And with these techniques,
the accuracy of the Lamb shift
is now one digit further
in the 10 kilohertz region.
There is a nice feature that
we'll also discuss later,
that it was possible to
obtain line weights, which
is [INAUDIBLE].
We'll talk about
it later, but it's
possible to do spectroscopy on
unstable states, which provides
line widths narrower than
the actual line widths.
If you want to get one
sentence as an appetizer,
you just look at the
atoms which have not
decayed for a long time,
and if you play some tricks,
you can then get line
widths which covers points
to several lifetimes, and not
just to the one [INAUDIBLE]
lifetime.
Some conditions have to
be met, and those authors
used it here to
advantage to narrow
the line for the measurement
of the Lamb shift.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The abstract
says that the result is not
in good agreement with theory.
What is the theoretical--
how far had it gone?
PROFESSOR: I don't
know it at this point.
I will later give you
comparison with theory
which is highly accurate.
I assume at this
point-- I'm not sure
if it was instrumental
difficulty.
I didn't [INAUDIBLE].
So these are the same authors
just a few years later.
The agreement between
theory and experiment
is two standard deviations, so I
think this problem disappeared.
I don't know if it was the
fault of theory or experiment.
But now we go a step forward
to optical spectroscopy.
You remember originally, and
this is why the Lamb shift was
not jumping into people's eye
when they did spectroscopy
of the Balmer
spectrum of hydrogen,
you cannot resolve
the structure.
The Lamb shift is
there, but it's
hidden in the envelope
of the unresolved lines.
And now the advent
of lasers, and people
immediately developed
saturation spectroscopy.
That's how most of
our laboratories
stabilize lasers using
Doppler-free saturation
spectroscopy.
And when saturation
spectroscopy was invented
by Hansch and Schawlow
for the first time,
you can break through
the Doppler [INAUDIBLE],
and now you see
the lines resolved.
And here, I think
for the first time,
you see two peaks
separated and the splitting
is the Lamb shift, which
until then was only accessible
through [INAUDIBLE]
frequency methods.
Of course, these were the first
lasers, just pulsed lasers,
and we couldn't even
think about precision.
But then, of course,
using metrology,
using frequency chains, people
could do precision measurements
in the optical domain.
These are now papers in the
'90s, "Optical Measurement
on the Lamb Shift in the Ground
State or in the Excited State."
Talking about the comparison
with experiment and theory,
experimental is pushed to
higher and higher precision,
and suddenly, there
was a discrepancy,
and it was a discrepancy
in the 1s Lamb shift.
In the 1s state, the
Lamb shift is much bigger
than in the 2s state because
the electron interacts much more
intimately with the [INAUDIBLE]
than the Coulomb potential is
on this.
People found that the
experiment did no longer
agree with theory.
But then the theorists had to
check all their assumptions,
and it was found that there
were two new binding corrections
which were surprisingly large.
Often, you make an estimate
that those terms are small.
You say it's higher
order, but you may not
know the pre-factor.
And here, something
was surprisingly large,
and by now you're
proving the theory.
There was again agreement
between experiment and theory.
It's getting now down
to the kilohertz level.
And at least as a few years
ago, this was state of the art.
Remember the Lamb shift is about
1,000 cycles one gigahertz,
and now the precision is
in the single kilohertz.
As I pointed out,
precision was reached
by directly measuring the
frequency of laser, frequency
metrology.
This was actually, for historic
interest, frequency metrology,
they used peak nodes
between the laser used
to measure the hydrogen
line and some other lasers.
This is just a few years
before comb generators.
Frequency combs completely
changed things again.
But they had already the
precision of a direct frequency
measurement.
You can read about
it when I paused it.
It shows you what
the [INAUDIBLE]
is in those installations.
This is a slide I
borrowed from Ted Hansch,
"Optical Spectroscopy
of Hydrogen."
It just shows the advances
in frequency metrology.
It shows how caesium clocks
and optical spectroscopy,
how they have
changed in precision,
and eventually, we
are now past the time
where optical spectroscopy is
more accurate than microwave
and radio frequency
spectroscopy.
Optical clocks are more accurate
than [INAUDIBLE] frequency
standards.
I'm sure in your
lifetime, you will
experience the
redefinition of this
again because the caesium clock
is no longer accurate enough
compared with the most
precise optical measurements.
And I think there was a peak
gap, a change in slope here.
In the old days, you measured
the wavelengths of light
by making a measurement of
the wavelengths using maybe
a grading or interferometry,
but when you now
started to measure
frequencies directly,
then there was a change in
slope and major improvements
in precision.
And today, of course, the
most precise measurement
of laser frequencies is not
through the wavelengths,
that they can count the number
of cycles in a peak node
with an optical comb generator.
So what can you do with
ever increasing precision?
This is also a slide I
borrowed from Ted Hansch.
If you measure very, very
accurately an atomic line,
let's say the 1s 2s transition
in hydrogen using two photon
spectroscopy, what you can
do is you can measure it,
and a few years later,
you can measure it again.
And now it becomes an
interesting question
if you have this precision.
Will the result be the
same as a function of time?
If there were a small change,
which there wasn't, you
could only come
to one conclusion,
and this is fundamental
common sense in nature,
change is a function of time.
So this precision
of metrology is now
being used to test the
fundamental constants, again,
constant as a function of time.
Precision is even
more improving.
The latest in the development
in the spectroscopy of hydrogen
is what is called the
size of the proton atom.
In your homework
assignment, you are actually
calculating what is the
correction due to transition
frequencies in
hydrogen because you
don't have a proton field
of a point particle.
The proton has a finite size.
Or vice versa, if you have
sufficient prediction,
if you have sufficient
accuracy of the measurement,
you can determine the
size of the proton
from the measured
transition frequencies.
This was done, and in 2010,
there was a big surprise
that the size of the proton
determined from hydrogen
spectroscopy did not agree
with scattering measurements
where you scatter electrons and
protons to measure the proton
size.
This is still a puzzle.
It's called the
proton radius puzzle,
and it is not clear
what is causing it.
What happened is in 2010,
there was a big improvement
in measuring the
size of the proton,
and this was done by replacing
the electron with a muon, which
is a heavy electron, but since
the muon is so much heavier,
the bore orbit of the muon,
the negative particle going
around the proton,
it is much smaller.
Therefore, the Lamb
shift also, but also
the correction due to the
finite size of the proton,
is much, much
larger because there
is much more overlay
of the muonic wave
function with a proton
than for an electron.
So there was a huge
improvement in the precision
of the measurement
of the proton size,
and this has really
led to what's
called the proton radius puzzle.
It's not sure if that is at the
same level of the Lamb shift,
which gave rise to
fundamental new physics.
Maybe this is the discovery
of the new Lamb shift in 2010,
and it changes our understanding
of fundamental physics,
but maybe it's something else.
The answer is not [INAUDIBLE].
At least this is 2010.
A few years of
checking the theory
and checking the experiment has
not removed the discrepancy.
Rather to the contrary.
It has hardened that there
is some discrepancy which
needs to be resolved.
So this was just a
little shot of excursion,
a little bit of summary of
spectroscopy of hydrogen
over 80 years, from
precursors to the Lamb shift
to the proton radius puzzle.
AUDIENCE: So I
know the same group
was using the same technique to
measure deuterium, maybe helium
PROFESSOR: I think they want to
do it but they haven't done it.
That's what they plan to do.
AUDIENCE: That was my question.
PROFESSOR: So our
next topic are now
atoms in external
magnetic fields.
The first chapter is on fine
structure and the lambda g
factor.
But maybe more colloquially,
atoms in external fields
means that we add one
more vector to the mix.
In fine structure, we have
orbital angular momentum
and spin angular
momentum, and we
discussed how spin orbit
coupling eventually
couples L and S to J and so
on, but now, we extend the game
by one more vector, B, an
external magnetic field.
It really becomes a
player in the game
because you know that if you
have spin orbit coupling,
we use the vector model that
L and S couple and precess
around the axis of J, the
total angular momentum.
So the game we play when we
couple angular momentum is
that angular
momentum couple, they
precess around an axis
that involves some quantum
numbers and so on.
But now, you can add a
new quantization axis
with a magnetic field,
and then angular momenta
will precess around
the magnetic field.
And there may be
actually a conflict,
that for strong magnetic
field, the precession is
different than in
weak magnetic fields,
and this is what we
want to discuss now.
So it is the game
of L, S, and B.
So what we are adding
with magnetic fields
is we are adding one term
to the Hamiltonian, which
is the Zeeman term, where we
have an external magnetic field
and we couple with
a magnetic moment.
The one thing which
makes it interesting
when we discuss fine
structure is the following,
that we have actually two
components to the angular
momentum of the atom,
which is the spin
and the orbital
angular momentum,
and the two have
different g factors.
So it's not that
the magnetic moment
is just proportional to
the angular momentum.
If the angular momentum
comes from spin,
it has a different weight than
when the angular momentum comes
from orbital angular
momentum, and this
is what we want
to now understand.
We want to determine what
is the magnetic moment
of the atom when the
angular momentum has
two different sources?
What we will find is we will
find that there is a lambda g
factor which is sometimes
2, which is sometimes 1,
or which is sometimes
somewhere in between,
depending how S
and L are arranged
with respect to each other.
So our Hamiltonian is the
Hamiltonian for the atom.
We know that we
have fine structure,
we discussed that,
which couples L and S.
And now have a magnetic
moment due to the spin
and due to the orbital
angular momentum,
and then couples to the
external magnetic field.
In other words, if we had
no fine structure coupling,
if S and L would not
be coupled, the answer
would be very simple.
S just couples to
the magnetic field,
gives the same [INAUDIBLE],
the g factor of 2,
and L couples to the magnetic
field with a g factor of 1.
But now the two are coupled
with respect to each other,
and if you have L-S coupling,
the projection of S and L
on the z-axis is not a good
quantum number anymore.
So therefore, we have
two different terms
which are diagonal in
two different bases,
and that's what we
want to discuss.
So the g factor of orbital
angular momentum is 1.
The g factor of the
spin is 2, or if you
want to include the leading
correction here from QED,
it's the fine structure
constant over 2 pi.
We did discuss that
the fine structure can
be related as the Zeeman
energy of the spin
in a magnetic field
which is created
by the electron
due to its motion.
Or, if you take the
frame of the electron,
the electron sees
the proton orbiting
around that creates
a magnetic field,
and this magnetic field
couples to the state.
So therefore, we can
associate fine structure
with an internal magnetic
field inside the atom.
And this internal magnetic
field is rather large.
It's on the order of 1 Tesla.
So therefore, for our discussion
of the lambda g factor and fine
structure in applied
magnetic fields,
we will assume that we are
in the weak field limit
where the fine structure
term, the first term,
is much larger than
the Zeeman term.
Of course, if you use
very strong magnets,
you can go to the
high field case,
but I will discuss explicitly
the transition from weak field
to high field for
hyperfine structure,
and the phenomenon
for fine structure
is completely analogous.
It just happens at
much higher fields.
So anyway, I will discuss the
high field case and transition
with the high field case with
a much more elegant example
of hyperfine structure
that you can immediately
apply to fine
structure if you like.
If I want to solve the problem,
calculate the lambda g factor,
I could directly calculate
just one matrix element
and it would be done.
So all I want to know
is what is the Zeeman
energy because Zeeman energy
divided by the magnetic field
is the magnetic moment.
And since I assume that I'm
in the weak field limit,
I can simply use the
quantum numbers S, L, and S
and L coupled to J, and the
magnetic quantum number is nJ.
So by simply calculating this
expectation value, I'm done
and I've solved the problem.
However, I want to do the
derivation using the vector
model because it provides
some additional insight.
So in the vector model, we
have L and S coupled to J
to the total angular momentum.
And in the vector model, we
assume that L and S rapidly
precess around J. And therefore,
the only thing which matters
are the projections.
Only the projections of L and
S on the J-axis are important.
So you can say if you have an
rapid precession of L and S
around J, the transverse
components rapidly average
out and [INAUDIBLE].
So therefore, our
Zeeman Hamiltonian
has to be rewritten
in the following way.
The Zeeman Hamiltonian
was the magnetic moment
times the external magnetic
field with a minus sign.
But what matters is the
projection on the J direction,
so we do the
projection in this way.
And also, in the
end, what matters
is, since the magnetic
moments are aligned with J,
it is now the scalar product
of the magnetic field with J.
So in the vector model, we
calculate the Zeeman energies
in that way, but just to
mention that if you don't
like the vector model and the
assumption of rapid precession,
just take this matrix element.
It's exactly the same.
In other words, I give
you the intuitive picture
what is inside those
matrix elements.
So let's evaluate that.
Let me factor out
the Bohr magneton.
We have J squared, taking
one of each bracket.
And now assuming that the
g factor of the spin is 2,
the magnetic moment is the
Bohr magneton times L--
the g factor of L is 1-- plus
S, but the g factor of S is 2.
So this is now the
magnetic moment accounting
for the two different g factors
we projected on the J-axis.
And the second racket,
B dot J becomes
the value of the magnetic field.
We assume the magnetic field
points in the z direction,
so therefore, it is the z
component of the total angular
momentum.
Let me collect the simple terms.
Now L plus 2S,
because L plus S is J,
can be written as J plus S.
So now we have the product
of J with J, which gives us
J squared, and then we need
the product of S and J.
And as usual, we can get
an expression for that
by using the summation
of angular momenta.
If we square it on
the right hand side,
we have the scalar
product of J and S,
but we have now the
scalar product of J and S
expressed by L
squared J squared.
J squared plus S squared minus
L squared divided by J squared.
Now, we're just one line
away from the final result.
Jz is a good quantum number.
It's MJ, the projection
of the total angular
momentum on the z-axis.
The bracket here is
now the famous result
for the lambda g factor.
So we have J squared over J
squared, which gives us 1.
And then I simply put
in the quantum numbers
for J squared, S
squared, L squared, which
is J times J plus 1
plus S times S plus 1
minus L times L plus 1, and
we divide by 2 times J plus 1.
So therefore, the Zeeman
structure in a magnetic field
is the Bohr magneton
times the magnetic field
times the angular momentum
in the J direction,
but then we multiply
with the g factor.
These are now limiting cases.
If we do not have spin,
then the only ingredients,
the only [INAUDIBLE]
angular momentum
is orbital angular momentum
and we have a g factor of 1.
So the lambda g factor
simply becomes gL.
In the case we don't
have angular momentum,
you can just evaluate this
expression for L equals 0.
You find indeed that
the g factor is 2.
But it can have
different values.
It depends on the
atomic structure.
That's all I want to
say about fine structure
in a magnetic field.
The next step is now
hyperfine structure.
We are adding one more
vector to the game.
So we add angular
momentum of the nucleus,
so now the game being
played is not only L and S.
We have I and B. It's a
game of the four vectors
and eventually how they
precess around each other,
and that gives rise to the
structure of hyperfine levels
in an external magnetic field.
We assume that L and
S have coupled to J,
so we have actually
a coupling of J, I,
but now we have an external
quantization axis in Zeeman.
It has to be due to the
external magnetic field.
And of course, in
hyperfine structure,
we discussed that I and J are
no longer conserved angular
momenta because they couple to
a total angular momentum, which
is F.
So our Hamiltonian
is the Hamiltonian
without any kind of
hyperfine and fine structure
when we have the hyperfine
coupling, which couples I
and J with the product
I dot J. And then we
have an external magnetic
field, which couples
to the magnetic moment
of the electron.
This may be a smaller term, but
you can easily carry with us.
There's also a coupling with the
magnetic moment of the nucleus.
So in this case, because
the hyperfine structure
is smaller than
the fine structure,
I want to discuss both the
weak field and the strong field
case.
Because magnetic fields of
a few hundred [INAUDIBLE]
may actually take into
the high field momentum.
I want to discuss both the low
field and the high field limit.
The low field limit implies
that the Zeeman energies
are much smaller than
the hyperfine splittings.
And then the way we describe the
system is that J and I couple.
So J, which is responsible
for the magnetic moment,
precesses around F, the
total angular momentum,
but then the total
angular momentum
precesses around
the magnetic field.
In other words, you assume that
the coupling between J and I
is so strong and
they couple to F,
the magnetic field
is not breaking up
the coupling between J and
I. J and I together form F,
and this hyperfine state,
this magnetic moment,
precesses around B.
This is sort of the picture.
You have to get used to it.
J precesses around
F and F precesses
around the external
magnetic field, B0.
But again, if you don't
like the precession model,
just calculate the
quantum mechanical energy
that will stabilize
the Hamiltonian.
The answer is identical.
The Zeeman Hamiltonian
couples to the magnetic field,
and we have two contributions
to the magnetic moment,
the electron of the nucleus.
And in the weak field
limit, we use a treatment
which is almost completely
analogous to the treatment we
used when we derived the
[INAUDIBLE] g factor.
We can treat the
same as Hamiltonian
perturbation theory, and
it's exactly analogous
when we added a weak magnetic
field to the fine structure.
In the vector model, we
have the coupling of J and I
to F. The relevant
term in the Hamiltonian
is we have the magnetic
moment of the electron, which
is proportionate to J
and it couples to B.
So this relevant term, this
is fully analogous to what
I did five or 10
minutes ago, has
to be replaced in the presence
of the nuclear angular
momentum.
We have to project everything
on the axis of the total angular
momentum, F.
Therefore, the
Zeeman Hamiltonian
had the contribution
to the magnetic moment
due to the electron
and due to the nucleus.
This is proportionate
to J, but now we
have to project it onto F. And
similarly, the magnetic moment
of the nucleus is
proportionate to I,
but what matters is
the projection on F.
And since I factored
out the Bohr magneton,
the magnetic moment
of the nucleus
is proportionate to
the nuclear magneton.
I have to account for the ratio.
What matters now is the
projection of F on B0.
So therefore, collecting
all the terms,
we have the Bohr
magneton, which is
setting the scale
of the interaction.
The last term is
the magnetic field,
but the projection of F
onto the magnetic field
gives us the mF quantum
number, and all the rest
is called the g factor of
the hyperfine structure.
And the g factor of
the hyperfine structure
is-- let me just
simplify and neglect
the small contribution--
it's 1,000 times smaller--
of the nuclear magnetic
moment, but if you want,
you can easily include it.
With this approximation,
the g factor
of the hyperfine
structure is this.
It's proportionate to the
lambda g factor we just derived.
And then using exactly
the same thing,
you have J dot F. You
can express it now
by the quantum numbers of F
squared, J squared, I squared.
You find the final
result, what are
the g factors of the
hyperfine levels,
of the hyperfine states.
So this is the hyperfine
structure of atoms [INAUDIBLE]
magnetic fields.
Let's immediately go to
the high field limit.
The high field limit means that
the electronic Zeeman energy
is much larger than
the hyperfine coupling.
And that means always,
when we treat the problem,
we first take care of
the big contributions
to the Hamiltonian.
We try to solve it, if
possible, [INAUDIBLE].
And then the weaker term
can be any perturbative.
So now we are in the situation
that the Zeeman coupling
is the big term and
the hyperfine coupling
is the weaker term.
So in other words, what comes
first now is the Zeeman energy,
so we are not coupling the
electronic angular momentum
and the nuclear angular momentum
to total angular momentum
because this coupling is weak.
We rather say that
the electronic
and the nuclear angular momentum
align with the magnetic field.
We quantize along the direction
of the magnetic field,
and then later we add
the hyperfine coupling
in a determinative way.
So B0 now quantizes
J along the direction
of the magnetic field,
and therefore we use,
as a good quantum
number, J, the projection
of J on the external
magnetic field axis.
So this takes care of J. J and
mJ are good quantum numbers.
What about I?
Does the nuclear
angular momentum
and the nuclear magnetic
moment strongly couple
to the magnetic field?
Well, the answer is
yes, but the argument
is a little bit more subtle.
The direct coupling
of the magnetic moment
of the nucleus with
the magnetic field
may be smaller than the
hyperfine interaction.
So then you would say, the
nuclear angular momentum
should not couple to
the magnetic field.
It should first be coupled
to the hyperfine interaction.
The hyperfine interaction
is I dot J. However,
J, which couples strongly
to the magnetic field
because it couples
to the Bohr magneton,
has already been coupled
to the magnetic field.
So therefore, the hyperfine
interaction, which is I dot J,
is now modified
because J couples
to the magnetic
field, which means
we have to project it onto
the magnetic field axis.
So therefore, the
nucleus now experiences
an electronic magnetic moment
or electronic angular momentum,
which has already been
coupled to the z-axis.
And therefore, the
hyperfine interaction
is also coupling the nuclear
angular momentum to the z-axis.
So therefore, the
result is that it is now
this indirect coupling.
You couple the electron
angular momentum to the z-axis
and the electron
angular momentum
couples the nuclear angular
momentum to the z-axis.
So now this quantizes the
nuclear angular momentum
along the z-axis,
which means that n
sub I becomes a
good quantum number.
Anyway, maybe the result is even
simpler than the explanation.
Our Zeeman
Hamiltonian now simply
means that we have an
external magnetic field
and you the electron couples
to the magnetic field,
so what matters is
the projection, mJ.
The same happens for the
nuclear magnetic moment,
and now we have to add the
hyperfine interaction, which
was originally I dot J, but
since I and J are projected
on the z-axis, what is really
left over are only mI and mJ.
I could have gotten this
expression immediately
by just telling you, J and
I no longer couple to F.
This is destroyed by a
strong magnetic field,
and the good quantum numbers are
J and I and their projection,
mJ and mI.
And then just writing
down the expectation value
of the Hamiltonian
in these spaces
would have immediately
given me this result.
I wanted to give you the more
mechanistic explanation what's
going on inside the atom and
what leads to this result.
I have discussed for you the two
limiting cases, the weak field
and the strong field case,
but you can solve it also
for intermediate fields.
You simply have to do
an exact diagonalization
of the Hamiltonian,
which involves
the hyperfine coupling.
And the hyperfine
coupling, if you want,
can be diagonalized
as eigenfunctions
where the quantums numbers
are J, I coupled to F,
and the projection of F, the
magnetic quantum number is mF.
But now we have the Zeeman
Hamiltonian, where everything
is projected on the z-axis,
so we have mJ and mI.
And the Zeeman term
can be diagonalized
in a different basis, which is
the basis of J, I, mJ, and mI.
So I've shown you the weak
field limit, where we simply
assume those quantum
numbers and calculate
this term determinatively, and
I've shown you the high field
limit, where we used
those quantum numbers
and calculated this
field determinatively.
But in general, you
just have to write down
the matrix element of this
Hamiltonian in whatever basis
you choose.
You can use the
weak field basis.
This term is diagonal.
This is off diagonal.
Or you can use the
strong field basis
where this is the diagonal
and this is off diagonal
and simply diagonalize
your Hamiltonian.
Find the wave function,
find the I energies.
And since, for cases
where S equals 1/2,
it's only a two by two matrix
which has to be diagonalized,
you can do it
analytically, and this
leads to the famous
[INAUDIBLE] formula.
So the solution is
analytic for J equals 1/2,
and it's a beautiful
example which
you should solve in your
homework assignment.
Let me just sketch the solution.
When you go from the weak field
to the strong field limit,
the z component of the total
angular momentum in one case
is mF.
In the other case,
it is mI plus mJ.
So when you go from
one limit to the next,
you connect only states
where mI plus mJ equals mF.
So the structure of
the general solution
can be explained by repulsion
and anti-crossings of states
with the same
[INAUDIBLE] number.
So let me show you the weak
field, the strong field limit,
and do a graphic interpolation.
What I've chosen as an example
is the case of a 2 duplet S 1/2
ground state and a nuclear
angular momentum of 3/2.
Examples for that is
sodium and rubidium 87.
This is magnetic field.
At weak magnetic field
or zero magnetic field,
the spin 1/2 couples
to the nucleus in 3/2,
and that gives to
hyperfine states F
equals 1 and F equals 2.
The splitting is given by
the hyperfine constant, a,
and the hyperfine interaction
is A times H times I times S.
The structure is such that the
center of mass of the energy
levels is preserved,
so therefore, one state
is moved up by 3/4 a.
The other state is
moved down by 5/4.
And since F equals 1
has three components,
F equals 2 has five
components, the center of mass
is preserved.
We have calculated the g
factor for those states,
and the g factor
tells us what is
the structure in
weak magnetic fields.
So this is the weak
magnetic field solution.
At high magnetic
field, you know what
you have in high magnetic field.
You have a single electron
which can spin up and spin down.
So if you have an electron
which is spin up and spin down,
it pretty much is linear
Zeeman shift for spin down
and linear Zeeman
shift for spin up.
This is sort of what we expect.
So what will happen is
that the energy levels
will evolve like this.
So in other words,
we have eight levels.
We have the structure
at weak magnetic fields.
At high magnetic
fields, of course,
we also have eight levels, but
they pretty much group into
spin up of the electron,
spin down of the electron.
And then there is a
smaller hyperfine structure
on top of it because
now the nuclear spin
can have various orientations.
And I equals 3/2 state
has four orientations,
so therefore, electron spin
up and electron spin down
will obtain four sub-levels.
And if you ask how
did I connected,
I've connected the quantum
numbers as such what is here,
the states are
labeled by mI and mS,
and here, they're
labeled by mF, but mF
equals mI plus mS. This
is how you correlate
the states in the
high field case
to the states in
the low field case.
I'm running out of time, but
here, we have mJ equals 1/2.
Here we have the
electron spin minus 1/2.
These four levels are now
four different quantum numbers
for the nuclear
angular momentum, which
are minus 3/2, minus 1/2,
plus 1/2, and plus 3/2.
And this is what I meant
by avoided crossing.
At some point, I think,
draw it yourself,
put the quantum numbers
on it, and you'll
learn a lot by doing it.
What you realize also when
you solve the Hamiltonian
that this structure can be
explained the following way.
You will always find you
have some states which
are stretched, where there
is only one state which
has the maximum angular
momentum inside all
the stretched states.
And then the other
states, you always
need to find two states
which have the same total mF,
and those two states
avoid each other.
You can say, just pointing on
two states, those two states,
let's just assume
they have the same mF.
They undergo an
avoided crossing,
and that's exactly
what you get out
of the diagonalization
of the two by two matrix.
So this whole diagram
can be understood
by you have stretched states
which form a one by one matrix.
There is no recoupling
taking place.
And then you have three pairs
of states which form two
by two matrix, and in each pair,
if you would now focus on it,
you really see the avoided
crossing typical for a two
by two matrix.
Any questions about that?
The next thing would be to go
through some bigger questions
and review atomic
structure, including
external magnetic fields.
But we'll do that at the
beginning of the next class.